[MUSIC PLAYING]
YUFENG GUO: My
name is Yufeng Guo.
Welcome to the dev zone.
And I'm joined today
by Minhaz Kazi.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yufeng is developer
advocate for machine learning
and cloud AI, and I'm developer
advocate for Google Data
Studio.
And today we're going to talk
about from data to dashboard,
a machine learning adventure.
So the way it started is
once upon a time, Yufeng
and I decided that we are
going to build a company.
YUFENG GUO: Some kind of
a-- maybe call it a startup,
perhaps.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yeah.
So we'll have a startup.
Now, Yufeng works
in machine learning.
I work in data viz.
So we thought, can we put
these two together, and maybe
create a company, and
then make lots of money?
YUFENG GUO: Some kind
of a successful company,
like a startup.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes, some
kind of a startup.
YUFENG GUO: Some
MINHAZ KAZI: That
would be a good idea.
But what is this
company going to do?
What are we going to sell?
What are we going to make?
YUFENG GUO: Just throw some ML
and data visualization at it.
It'll be fine.
Right?
We need to look at how we can--
yes, how we can make
a turboencabulator.
Has anyone heard of
a turboencabulator?
I've got a spec here.
It's based on the principle
of data generation
by the modal interaction
of magnetic reluctance
and capacitive reluctance.
And the ML turboencabulator
will negate
the relative motion of
conventional conductors
and fluxes.
Yep.
OK.
Let's just move on.
MINHAZ KAZI: Let's
just move on, yeah.
So what is our plan?
YUFENG GUO: So we'll collect
some successful information,
some information about
successful companies
from all over the US.
And we're going to try to
emulate successful companies.
That's what everyone
does, right?
We try to emulate those
that are successful.
And we'll analyze that data.
We'll do some machine learning,
try to come up with things
like what should we
call our company,
who should run our
company, maybe where
do we want the company to be.
And hopefully we'll
have some profit
with our turboencabulator.
MINHAZ KAZI: So this is the
dataset we started with.
We used the INC 5000 dataset of
America's top growing companies
where there was data
available for the top 5,000
companies that had the highest
growth rate over a total three
years.
And this is what
the data looks like.
It had information on the
year the company was founded,
the rank of the company
on the growth chart,
then the name of the
company, when it was founded,
which location it
was founded in,
the state, the revenue
amount, and also
the growth amount, the
industry, and the headcount.
YUFENG GUO: Yeah.
And we were looking at this,
and we were thinking, hm,
maybe we can get
something out of this
to get some insights about what
makes a company successful.
Is it these factors, or
is it something that's not
necessarily captured in here?
So this is a big list.
It's over 5,000.
MINHAZ KAZI: 5,000 rows.
Wow.
YUFENG GUO: It's not
a 50-company list
or a 100-company list.
We have 5,000 companies.
That's some really big data.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
And for very big data,
we need big firepower.
YUFENG GUO: That's right.
And that means to search through
this big, 5,000-long list,
we need some big
queries as well.
MINHAZ KAZI: That's right.
So we decided to put
our data into BigQuery.
And so we would put our
5,000 rows in BigQuery
and run queries on
it, run analyses,
and try to figure out what makes
these companies successful.
YUFENG GUO: So the data we
had--D we took the data,
and we put it into BigQuery, and
then we tried to see what kind
of visual insight we
could get out of it.
So to get the visual
insight, what we did
is we used Data Studio to
connect to the BigQuery
dataset, and then take the
data, and get some insight out
of the data.
So to do that, we
went to Data Studio.
We selected the BigQuery.
We picked our dataset, and
then we connected to it.
So once you connect
to it, it gives you
the overview of the data.
As you can see, this is
what the data looks like,
the entire scheme of the data.
And then once we
connect to the dataset,
it gives us a blank canvas
where we can create our viz.
So let's try to
create our first viz.
We'll try to add a
bar chart, and we'll
try to see the average
revenue of companies.
So I'll try to find, by
industry, the average revenue.
And you can see
there is a 0 here.
0 means for these companies,
the industry was not defined.
So let's try to filter that out.
So we'll add a custom filter,
and we'll create a new filter.
We'll say exclude all
industry that is basically 0.
We save that.
And you can see
that the security
industry has the most highest
average revenue per company.
MINHAZ KAZI: It's
because they're all
securing that revenue, right?
YUFENG GUO: Yes.
They're very secure about
their revenues, and also
the logistics and
transportation,
because they're
transporting their revenues.
MINHAZ KAZI: Exactly.
YUFENG GUO: So we'll try
to add maybe one more chart
and try to look at
how the exact number--
or maybe how the
number of companies
look like across states.
So we'll add the state
variable, and we'll
add the rank, or
maybe record count.
So how many companies are there
from that list in each state?
And let's apply some filters.
And as we view the dashboard, we
can see most of these companies
are in California,
then in Texas, Florida.
If we try to, let's say, filter
down, if we click on Virginia,
it shows us that in
Virginia, insurance companies
are doing the best, and followed
by government services, which
makes sense because
it's close to DC.
MINHAZ KAZI: Exactly.
And what I really
like about this
is that you were able to make
an auto-filtering interactive
chart without having to do
any sort of coding to make
that clickable filtering work.
YUFENG GUO: Exactly.
And we did completely
serverless,
completely on Google
Cloud, because the data was
in BigQuery, and
the viz is being
done in Data Studio, which you
can just use from your browser.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yeah.
Super handy, just
like bing, bang, boom.
YUFENG GUO: So we
used this dataset
and created a
dashboard beforehand.
This is what the
dashboard looks like.
On the left side, we have
a number of companies
by industry, and then we
have number of companies
by state in this geochart.
We're showing the average
state of the companies that
are coming up in
this filtered view.
When did the companies start?
And there's also an insight from
what are the outlier companies.
So we have the top 100
ranks here and the revenue
of the companies.
And we can see that there
are three outliers here.
The first one is Carbana.
Then the second
one here is Avant.
And we have another outlier
here, which is the PANTHERx.
MINHAZ KAZI: Specialty pharmacy.
YUFENG GUO: Yes.
And we can even filter it here.
If we click on
Health, it will filter
across all of the other charts
and show you a filtered view
of the entire data.
So from this dashboard,
we tried to figure out,
which industry should we be in?
Which state should we be in?
So it looks like California
is the state where
we have to be in, because most
of these successful companies
are there.
So if we establish our
company in California,
we have a very good probability
of being successful.
MINHAZ KAZI: That's
right, because correlation
is causation.
YUFENG GUO: Exactly.
So that was our dashboard.
Now the most
important decision we
had to make about our company.
Can anyone guess what was
the most important decision?
We already did location.
We already did
industry, kind of.
What other things?
What other factors are there?
What is the single most--
name?
I heard name a couple of times.
What should we call
our own company?
It's got to be catchy.
It's got to make sense
but be a little bit edgy.
And so how can we make
this critical decision?
Well, we'll look to our data.
We've got 5,000 companies.
And we can take that,
and we can stick it
into a machine learning
model that will actually
generate us names that are
similar to these companies.
We want to be like them.
We want to be like the
top 5,000 companies.
And so you have a lot of
options of how to do this.
Basically, what we did was
we took the BigQuery data,
pulled out that column,
put it into Colabratory,
and ran a recurring
neural network
to make those generated models.
And we spit out some very
interesting company names.
And what's neat
about this, I found,
was that with
generative models, you
can set what's
called a temperature.
And the temperature
determines how
creative the model decides to
be, how wacky it decides to be.
And on one end of
the spectrum, we
have extremely normal names,
names that show up repetitively
or words that are very common.
And so they're kind of safe.
And on the other side of
the temperature spectrum,
you have really,
really creative names.
You might have--
well, what might
be viewed as misspellings,
but sometimes that's
a good thing for companies.
And you might have things that
just make no sense at all.
And then in between, you
have in-between stuff.
And so looking at this list,
which ones do you think
are real, companies that
really exist out in the world,
and which ones were
just completely made up,
we just generated
from the model?
Can you tell them apart?
MINHAZ KAZI: Let's
take the first one.
How many people think the
first one is a real company?
YUFENG GUO: Yeah.
That first one is
Sofe & Motores.
MINHAZ KAZI: How many people
think it was generated?
YUFENG GUO: All right.
OK.
What about the second
one, the Lollicup USA?
How many people think it's real?
Lollicup USA is real?
OK.
Lollicup USA is fake.
It was about half
and half on that one.
Interesting.
MINHAZ KAZI: We can
do the third one.
YUFENG GUO: Yeah,
let's do the third one.
MINHAZ KAZI: Persoft-- real?
Persoft-- fake?
YUFENG GUO: Another 50-50.
MINHAZ KAZI: Cool.
YUFENG GUO: Who didn't vote?
All right.
Let's go on and take a look.
So I guess we should
give it away now.
The left side are all fake, and
the right side are all real.
So Lollicup is real.
Persoft is fake.
And Sabot is also real.
MINHAZ KAZI: It's also real.
YUFENG GUO: Yeah.
And so here are some
other names that we
generated in addition to those.
And we've colored it by
this temperature metric.
So at the top of the list are
fairly creative company names.
Now, remember,
these are all fake.
Not a single one of
these companies is real.
And then at the bottom are names
that are really safe, similar.
And you can see there's a
little bit of a pattern.
It seems that
companies really like
to call themselves solutions
or systems or services.
And they want to
cover all the things.
MINHAZ KAZI: So that
gives us an idea
that we will call our
company All Systems Solutions
Services, trademark pending.
YUFENG GUO: It will be the most
successful company name ever.
It will be instantly
recognizable and etched
into the minds of our customers.
MINHAZ KAZI: Definitely.
YUFENG GUO: All right.
So this leads us to
the other question.
Aside from the
name of the company
is whose name will
be in that CEO slot.
Who should run the company?
Well, we can use the same
technique as we did before
and try to make
up some names too.
We've got a list
of 5,000 founders,
and they're all in the top
5,000 companies in the country.
So again, who's real,
and who doesn't exist?
Raise your hands if
you think Andy Garen is
a real person who runs a
company in the top 5,000.
Who thinks that
Andy Garen does not
exist, it's totally made up?
MINHAZ KAZI: Quite a few people
think Andy doesn't exist.
YUFENG GUO: Poor Andy.
MINHAZ KAZI: How
about Jeff Shall?
Jeff is real?
Jeff is not real?
All right.
I think people are catching on.
YUFENG GUO: Yeah.
Well, we've got to look
at the other side, though.
What about Dwayne Smith?
Is Dwayne Smith a real person?
And Dwayne Smith is
completely made up,
a computer-generated name?
So we've got to really
wake people up somehow.
We don't have any cupcakes to
throw at you, unfortunately.
I know it's still
technically morning.
So again, the
left-hand side is fake,
and the right-hand side is real.
So Dwayne Smith is real.
Jeff Shall is fake.
And we can see some
other examples of names.
We have some more creative names
toward the top that are not--
some of them, like
the first one,
the last name,
FRNI, a little short
on the vowels in
the letter ordering.
But for the most
part, these names kind
of sound real for the most
part, especially the ones
in the middle.
It's not the worst.
MINHAZ KAZI: They seem
like names of real people.
YUFENG GUO: Apparently
people like the name Jeff.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yeah.
I think we should be hiring Jeff
Gardor or maybe Chris Martin
to run the company.
But--
YUFENG GUO: They don't
exist, so we can't hire them.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
I know what we should do.
Let's change our names.
You can name yourself Jeff,
and I can call myself Chris.
YUFENG GUO: All right.
Nice to meet you, Chris.
MINHAZ KAZI: Nice
to meet you, Jeff.
So that way, since
we've changed our names
and we have these
names, the model
predicts that our company
will be successful.
YUFENG GUO: Absolutely.
Successful name,
successful names.
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
YUFENG GUO: So this brings
us to the next question.
We don't just want to
be in the top 5,000.
We want to be toward the
top of the top 5,000.
Right?
And so let's take a look at how
we might go about doing that.
So I've got the data.
We dumped out of BigQuery.
I did a little bit of
cleaning up on BigQuery.
And the screen--
OK-- did a flash.
And so we'll import
TensorFlow in Keras.
And in this case, I'm
pulling into Pandas.
And what I'm going
to do is we'll
try to take some of the
statistics that are coming out
of this dataset and load
it into a Keras model
to basically try to build a
model that can predict which
quintile a given
company will be falling
in given things like
what state it's in,
the growth percentage, headcount
numbers, and its industry,
and its revenue.
And so I've processed
out the quintile.
So I added the quintile
column in BigQuery
to basically do a
division by 1,000.
And then we can see some
interesting statistics
about our columns.
There's 26 unique
industries in this dataset.
We've got 52 states thanks to
Puerto Rico and Washington, DC.
And we have-- let's see--
any other notables?
The ranges of the revenue I
found to be pretty interesting.
I know it's written in
scientific notation, so
apologies in advance.
But the minimum threshold to
make this 5,000 the lowest
revenue annually was
$1.7 million, basically.
So these are not the
smallest companies.
But then when you get
to the higher end,
4.7 times 10 to the 9th is
$4.7 billion in revenue.
And these are all
privately held startups.
So we split the data up
into training and test.
And here I've actually split it
in half, just because we only
have 5,000 companies.
I'm not going to show the
model all these companies.
Then I have nothing
to do predictions on.
So I just show it
half, and we'll
save half to use and make some
predictions on at the end.
Then we'll grab our--
the columns we want,
split them down.
And then I've got my training
input functions, et cetera.
And then what I've
done here is I've
used TensorFlow's feature
columns, which is a way
to do some feature engineering.
I find that having the right
tool for the right task
is really important.
In BigQuery, making an
actual column for quintiles
and doing a little bit of date
manipulation was really easy.
And so I did it there
because it came to mind.
But then as I went
through the process
and I was [INAUDIBLE]
doing a few things there,
those were the
discoveries I made there
around what I needed to do.
I could just do them right then.
And then when I actually started
loading it into the model,
I realized, things like
growth, it's just a number.
And the growth ranges
all over the place.
So I took the quintile,
the percentiles--
the 25th percentile,
the 50th percentile,
and the 75th percentile values
for some of these columns
and bucketized them so that--
because I don't care if
the growth is 40% or 50%.
That's roughly the same thing.
So I want the model to
recognize it as such.
I've done the same thing
here with headcount
and with revenue.
And revenue is
especially notable
because the ranges are
all over the place.
And so knowing where
the percentiles are
helps you get a nice, even
distribution of your data
across the buckets.
And so with all the
feature columns set up,
I made two different
models, a linear model
and a deep learning model.
So the linear model did
pretty good, I'd say,
all things considered.
When I finished evaluating,
we came out to about 76%.
My accuracy-- I could
keep training longer.
I could keep banging my head
against the different features
and different columns,
add more data.
But all things considered, given
that the [INAUDIBLE] piece here
was when I first
started doing this
and I didn't have
any buckets at all,
I was getting, like, 20% error
accuracy, which is terrible.
So the changes really made
a meaningful difference.
And on the deep model side,
I just made a simple model.
It's a three-layer
model with 20, 15,
and 10 neurons per layer,
so not terribly large,
not terribly sophisticated.
But with that and training
for the same amount of time,
it got 86%.
So it's still not perfect.
I'm not looking for
perfection here,
but just seeing if we can
actually model this behavior.
And it seems like we can.
We can use information like
headcount, location, revenue,
and--
what else-- growth
percentage, things
like that, to actually predict
the successfulness of a given
company.
And so here we have a few--
let's see.
I already set this part up.
So we have the
different industries,
just I don't have
to type them all.
So if we want, we can actually
generate our own fake company.
We can say, I want a company
that's in the state of Maryland
and has had a growth of 203%
over the past three years,
doubled over three years.
Pretty reasonable for a startup.
MINHAZ KAZI: Sure.
YUFENG GUO: But I've only
got, like, 58 people.
Hiring has been a
little bit slow.
And let's see.
What industry is
should we be in?
Does anyone have a preference?
Feel free to shout it out.
Human resources.
OK.
So we'll be in human resources.
Where is human resources?
Here we go.
So we'll copy that, and
we'll put that down here
in our industry array.
OK, so human resources.
And how much revenue
do we want to have?
So we know that on
the low end of things,
it's about $1.7 million.
And on the high end of things,
we have about $4 billion.
So depending on
whether you believe
revenue is a big indicator
for growth and success
of the company,
with only 58 people,
how much revenue can we
really be expected to pull in?
MINHAZ KAZI: $100 million.
YUFENG GUO: $100 million.
What is that, to the 8th?
MINHAZ KAZI: Yes.
YUFENG GUO: All right.
So we'll say this much.
Got to love the [INAUDIBLE].
All right.
Still remember how
to use the computer.
That's good.
OK.
So that's $100 million today.
All right.
So let's run that.
And let's see.
Then we can-- I think the--
where's the cell for actually--
oh, right, because I'm
writing it to a file now.
All right.
So we'll just write those
results to the file.
I don't know if that's
going to work, though.
MINHAZ KAZI: So this
is going to predict
where this company is going to
end up in the ranking, which
quintile list.
It will be among the
first 20% or the next 20%.
It will predict that.
That's cool.
So then we can
potentially predict
that if we have a company
that's founded in California,
has a growth of 5,000%,
has only two headcount,
we could try to predict
if we are going to end up
in the first quintile.
YUFENG GUO: Yeah.
That kind of sounds like
the early days of Google.
A little bit, right?
MINHAZ KAZI: Or the early
days of All Systems Solutions
Services.
YUFENG GUO: All Systems
Solutions Services.
Yes.
Thank you.
MINHAZ KAZI: Definitely.
YUFENG GUO: And so what we've
actually gone ahead and done
is we took the other
half of the data
and ran it through our model,
and we outputted a CSV,
and passed that over to--
MINHAZ KAZI: Google Sheets.
And then from Google
Sheets, we have this data,
which shows the comparison
of the actual versus
predicted values.
YUFENG GUO: We're trying
to click, but it is--
all right.
It came up.
MINHAZ KAZI: So this
dataset basically shows
what was the actual
values of the comparison
and then what did it predict.
What is the predicted value?
It is waiting for cache.
YUFENG GUO: Waiting
for the Wi-Fi.
MINHAZ KAZI: And it is loading.
So as we did that, we
had the actual value
and the predicted value.
We tried to take
this dataset and see,
can we visualize this again?
So we again went
back to Data Studio,
and then we added back the data
and tried to visualize that.
And you can connect Data Studio
Dashboard to a Google Sheet.
So we did exactly that here.
We connected the dashboard to
that comparison data sheet.
And let's say we
will add in a chart.
And we will add a--
this did not get picked up.
When our company
gets up and running,
we'll have to fix our Wi-Fi.
YUFENG GUO: That's right.
Tell our employees to
stop streaming movies
while we're presenting.
Can't have that.
MINHAZ KAZI: So this
is our actual quintile
and predicted quintile.
And you can see the
comparisons come up.
And since this model
was pretty accurate,
for most of the companies,
this is exactly the same.
Now we can try to add
filters here and try to see,
can we find something
where these are not equal?
So let's say-- we will
try to filter by state.
View this dashboard.
And we should be able
to filter it and see
whether there are other datasets
where these don't match up.
So if we filter
for Virginia only--
YUFENG GUO: We got a
lot of West Coast love,
so we'll do a little East Coast.
MINHAZ KAZI: It's
still mostly the same.
So maybe there's one
or two hidden in there.
So that being
said, we showed you
how we can take the
outputs of the model
and then publish the insights
using the Data Studio
Dashboard.
And you can then
take this dashboard,
and then you can share
it with other people.
You can publish it and
embed it on websites.
So you can go from completely
a blank dataset, a new dataset,
to a published dashboard
results in a few minutes,
in a few clicks, in a completely
serverless environment.
So that basically
tells us our company
will be called All
System Social Services.
We'll be creating--
YUFENG GUO: And soon
to be in the INC 5,000.
And so we have a blank side.
So thank you so much for coming.
My name is Yufeng.
This is Minhaz.
And yeah, well, I guess we
are All Systems Solutions
Services, trademark,
copyright, registered, pending.
Cool.
[MUSIC PLAYING]